So I have to, to comment on your t-shirt. I think it says immigrants feed,
uh, America, which I could not agree more with. Uh,
and you have such an incredible personal narrative yourself. Uh,
you came to this country with next to nothing. Uh, you worked in a restaurant.
I know you've been back and forth to Spain and the U S but you,
your work, uh,
just kept on drawing more and more fans and support and, uh,
everywhere you went, people, um, wanted to,
to taste your food, really like, you know, is so much of it. Uh,
and I feel like your immigrant story is the story that so many
people came to this country to, uh,
have a chance at themselves just to try and create a better life for themselves
and their families. Uh, and I, you know, I'm the son of immigrants, myself, uh,
and you know, I know you've had your run-ins with, uh, our current president,
hopefully outgoing president over the fact that you were supposed to have a
restaurant in one of his establishment. And then you said, you know what?
I don't think I want to have a restaurant in this establishment and, uh,
and ended up, um, like, uh,
on the other side of the president there,
which I commended your,
or like I like many Americans thought that you were awfully, uh,
principled and courageous to make that stand. Um,
but I'm sure there were some negative effects, uh, uh,
as well that you had to deal with. Well.
Let me tell you, in my end of the day, I wake up and,
uh,
the president of United States is suing my company and myself personally.
And actually, because I was the right thing to do, I saw him back. Uh,
how many times do you have a president of the United States that is in a suit
with a citizen? I think it's the first. Um,
but they needed, because I,
I sincerely believe that that his comments on
Mexicans were you, uh,
not the right thing to be listening from a leader. Um,
um, and that the right thing to do was to stand up. Um,
many people told me you knew he will be compressed.
And will you do the same as a hundred times over? Yes.
I remember speaking with him, uh,
in the early days of his comments and he told me, don't worry if it's,
everything will be fine, Jose, we are winning. We're winning. Say,
Mr. Trump, I'm trying to open a restaurant.
I'm not running in your ticket. Uh, I'm not supporting your ticket.
I only want to have a successful restaurant. And I believe that we, the people,
uh, means that we should be respecting each other. I, it doesn't seem,
you're a person that respect others,
and I hope that you will change. I'll rephrase, uh, your comments.
I thought he was going to do.
I was so naive that I thought that I cook like me an immigrant,
like me could make a person again,
maybe to sound apologetic. I don't know.
I think that was naive at all. Jose. I like, like,
it was quite reasonable of you to think that.
He doubled down two weeks later and he is a mom. And, uh, so for me,
obviously you mentioned about my shirt, immigrants, immigration reform,
listen as an immigrant and as a Spanish American,
I'm very thankful about the amazing opportunity I gain by being
invited to join this country and by becoming American,
uh, you'll gain a lot of, um, uh,
I love things that these new country of ours gives us, but we've,
we've, we've becoming American.
Also you gain responsibilities to be a good citizen,
to give back to respect others and to give back as much as we received
from the country that welcomed us. Um,
but also we need to be aware of the big lie that we have on immigration
reform that we need to be also pragmatic.
We had chances with the democratic party that we didn't take on
on is, uh, everybody needs to be involved in passing immigration reform.
Dreamers is the first step.
How are we supposed to whether we have almost a million, uh, Americans,
because they may not have a passport, but to me,
sometimes you don't belong to a place because they give you a paper.
You belong a place because you were hard to be long. Those reamers,
they are earned our respect by becoming young citizens,
almost a million strong.
Do you know how long it takes to train a workforce of a
million people? This is a NASAD for America.
I always said that the immigration reform is not a problem for America to
solve. It's an opportunity for America to cease.
Dreamers should be part of the American dream today,
but who people think is being feeding
America through this pandemic, the people that are,
that we can afford to be playing golf.
Who do you think is taking care of those golf courses?
Who do you think is refilling the shelves?
Who do you think is working the farms every day from sunrise to
sunset sometimes, uh,
badly paid badly treated without any, uh,
PPE to make them safe.
Who do you think is the people that they'd been
putting America forward through this entire pandemic?
Many Americans in the,
in the middle lower class that they've been working day in and day out to
provide for the families, but indirectly to keep America moving,
but 11 million undocumented Americans I'm telling you,
they'd been in every corner of America through this pandemic,
moving America forward. Those men and women, they showed the value to America.
They show that they belong to America is about time that once,
and for all we pass comprehensive immigration reform.
America will win Republicans and Democrats will win because we all know an
undocumented. They are part of our lives. Our,
our communities is about time. We do this,
and I hope this pandemic towards 2021 will give the opportunity one day soon
enough to pass immigration reform,
to allow dreamers to belong and become American cities in some way,
not to give the opportunity to undocumented immigrants,
to have a legal status in this country.
Uh, it's heartbreaking that we have missed the opportunities we've had Jose,
you know, that there were windows when, uh,
bipartisan legislators came forward and said,
we need a comprehensive approach to immigration. And everyone knows it.
Unfortunately,
many politicians now feel like it's more advantageous to them to have
something, to make people upset, uh, than it is to,
to reach across the Island hammer out like, uh,
some kind of compromise or bi-partisan approach. Uh,
and we're seeing that in an, on multiple fronts,
unfortunately now with the pandemic, but immigration to me has to be very,
very high on that list of things that Americans know that we
need needed years ago to have a more rational approach,
a humane approach,
a more clear eyed approach for the reality of the fact that so many of our
communities rely upon immigrants every single day. Uh,
and so your t-shirt is very apt. Um,
it's so inspiring to me to see someone like you who's come here
made so much of yourself,
but then also throwing yourself into multiple important causes right now,
fighting for restaurant tours, uh, for immigrant rights,
but also you've led many humanitarian efforts around food and food
scarcity and food relief.
We need a white house that recognizes the problem we're facing.
And when you have a leader,
that seems not even to recognize we have a pandemic and
seems not to recognize how many businesses are suffering and
who instead of coming up with the smart ideas and bills to invest into
solutions seems is throwing money at the problem.
We mean pain farmers across America, the big farmers,
because very bad policy in the white house fight with
China, where actually now we are not better off. Uh,
maybe the precedent is showing, uh, uh,
everybody how strong he is against China by rhino with, uh,
spending more money, paying subsidies to our farmers,
that they are not even producing food because the war with China,
we've spent four or five times, uh,
in those subsidies to farmers that we spend when we had the
automobile crisis and is not great in jobs is
only throwing money at the problem. The president Luke's good,
but he's really writing checks to farmers in the process.
We are not feeding America. This is to me insane.
That's why we need policies that they don't look that they are good.
So you can get boats on election day,
but policies that empower Americans to do well all
across.
We need the white house that recognizes the pandemic until we don't have that
leadership in place.
Everything is going to be hard because we require a very big
approach idea to have a big investment to regrow
the economy towards 2021, 2022.
And right now I don't see that leadership in the white house or in the Senate.
Well, you know,
I'm on board Jose that we need a different set of leaders in the white house.
And hopefully we can turn the page for our country on November 3rd or
thereabouts. Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation.
If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.